عندما أعلن مركز السيطرة على الأمراض قبل أسابيع فقط
أن اللقاحات المرغوبة آمنة
للأطفال دون سن الخامسة ، كانت هذه أخبار
سارة كان العديد من الآباء الأمريكيين
ينتظرونها منذ أن بدأ الوباء ،
لكن لدينا الآن بعض الأخبار السيئة للغاية عن اللقاحات
للآباء والكثير من
بقية الأخبار.  أعلنت
منظمة الصحة العالمية في اليونيسف
الأسبوع الماضي أن
التطعيمات الروتينية للأطفال على مستوى العالم قد
انخفضت بشكل حاد منذ عام 2019 ، وهو أكبر
انخفاض مستمر منذ 30 عامًا
بحلول العام الماضي ، كانت النسبة المئوية للأطفال
الذين تلقوا جميع الجرعات الثلاث من
لقاح الخناق والسعال الديكي.
انخفض بمقدار 5 نقاط مئوية إلى 81
dtp هو معيار لتغطية التحصين
، ويعني الانخفاض أنه في عام 2021 وحده ، انخفض 25
مليون طفل لم
يحصلوا على جرعة اللقاح الأولى من لقاحات الحصبة
إلى 81 أيضًا ،
كما ارتفعت حالات الحصبة عالميًا بنسبة 80٪ تقريبًا.  في أوائل
هذا
العام ، انخفض متوسط
معدل التطعيم لـ 11 مرضًا رئيسيًا بما في ذلك
شلل الأطفال وفيروس الورم الحليمي
البشري  للمرة الأولى منذ أكثر
من 30 عامًا
، ارتفع عدد الأطفال الذين لم
يتلقوا جرعة واحدة من
اللقاحات الأساسية بشكل حاد في
الجائحة من 13 مليونًا في عام 2019 إلى 18
مليونًا في عام 2021.
لقد كانت اللقاحات
قصة أخبار سارة مذهلة في  الصحة العامة كما
تشير التقارير إلى أن منظمات مثل مؤسسة بيل
ومليندا غيتس قد ضخت
الموارد في التحصين الروتيني في
البلدان الفقيرة بمرور الوقت ،
ثم عكست معدلات التطعيم أو حتى تجاوزتها
في البلدان الغنية وانخفضت الوفيات الناجمة عن
الأمراض الشائعة بشكل حاد ، وهناك
العديد من أسباب الانخفاض  في
التحصين بما في ذلك الصراع
وتغير المناخ ، لكن
الانزلاق الخلفي على اللقاحات في جزء كبير منه هو نتيجة طبيعية
لفوضى سلاسل التوريد الوبائية التي
تعطلت الانتباه
وتم تحويل التمويل إلى
جهود طمعية ركزت عمليات الإغلاق
الاهتمام الفردي على البقاء اليومي
ولكن ما فاجأ الباحثين كان
حقيقة أن اللقاحات لم تنتعش
العام الماضي وأنها فعلية  ازداد سوء الوضع
بعد أن تلاشت الصدمات الأولى للوباء
من المؤخرة ، وهو أمر مثير للفضول لأن العديد من
البلدان نفسها التي سجلت
انخفاضًا حادًا في التحصينات الروتينية
تمكنت من طرح لقاح covet 19 بنجاح
في إندونيسيا حيث 62٪
من السكان كاملو  تم التطعيم
ضد الطمع 19.
لكن إندونيسيا سجلت انخفاضًا حادًا
في التطعيمات الروتينية ، حيث
يقدر أن النسبة المئوية
للأطفال المستهدفين بلقاح
dtp الذين تلقوا الجرعات الثلاث بالفعل
قد انخفضت من 85 في عام 2019 إلى 67 في المائة
العام الماضي
جزء من المشكلة هو الطبيعة  من
تدفقات تمويل التدخل في الصحة العامة نفسها ،
وغالبًا ما يتم عزل برامج التطعيم ، مما يعني مع بعض
الاستثناءات الملحوظة أن السلطات
لم تجمع حملات التطعيم المرغوبة
مع التطعيمات الروتينية
ولكن هناك خطر آخر أدى
إلى تفاقم هذه المشكلة.
تشير التقارير إلى أن لديها
مؤيد تطعيم قوي تاريخيًا  غرام
لكن الرئيس جايير
بولسونارو انتقد لقاح كوفيت 19 في وقت مبكر ، وكثيرًا ما
أعلن أنه هو نفسه لم يتم
تطعيمه وأنه لن يقوم بتلقيح
ابنته البالغة من العمر 11 عامًا وأن
اللقاح يمكن أن يزيد من فرص
الإصابة بمساعدات فهو بالطبع ليس
مضادًا للقاح غامضًا  اكتسبت المجموعات
شراءًا في البرازيل خلال
الوباء في الأوقات التي تشير إليها الملاحظات وهذا ما زاد من حدة
هذا الشعور ، أصبحت
البرازيل الآن من بين 10 دول
بها أكبر عدد من الأطفال الذين
لم يتلقوا تطعيمًا واحدًا من أي
نوع ، ولم يتلق 26 بالمائة من جميع الأطفال في البرازيل
العام الماضي  تلقي
أي لقاحات ارتفعت من 13٪
في عام 2018.
أو انظر إلى الفلبين حيث
تكثر المعلومات الخاطئة عن لقاح covet 19 عمليات
الإغلاق القاسية ونقص
العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية أدى إلى هذا الواقع الصارخ
43٪ من جميع الأطفال الرضع هناك لم
يتلقوا بعد  جرعة واحدة من
اللقاحات الأساسية في العام الماضي لقاحات العام الماضي
هي من نواحٍ عديدة
ثمارها المتدلية من العامة  الصحة
هم غير مكلفون ويعملون
بسببهم نشأت أجيال
لا تضطر إلى الخوف من الأمراض التي
كانت منتشرة على نطاق واسع ،
وقد يكون التحصين الروتيني القاتل
ضحية نجاحه
للآباء الجدد الذين لم
يعشوا ويلات الحصبة وشلل الأطفال  قد
نأخذ هذا النجاح كأمر مسلم به
ولكن يجب أن نتذكر أن التقدم من
أي نوع في أي مجال ليس
حتميًا وبما أن العالم يصبح أكثر تقلبًا
دون بذل جهد مستمر
ويمكن بسهولة عكس تقدم اليقظة